قطاع النفط يشعل ازمه في الولايات المتحده
ويجعلها على صفيح ساخن قبيل ايام من اجراء
الانتخابات النصفيه الرئيس الامريكي يصعد
ضد شركه النفط الامريكيه وهددها بزياده
الضرائب لدفعها الى خفض الاسعار متهما
اياها بخفض الانتاج بايضا استخدم التهديد
نفسه في بدايه تسليمه الرئاسه لكنه كان
يضغط على الشركات ذاتها لوقف وخفض الانتاج
لمراعاه البيئه
رفضت زياده الانتاج للحفاظ على ارباحها
وان بيضا محبط مشيره الى توقيت تصعيد
الرئيس الامريكي قبل الانتخابات النصفيه
لكبرى شركه الطاقه الامريكيه من بينها
شيفرون واكسون حذروا من خطوره فرد ضرائب
غير متوقعه محتمله
خطاب بايد ان كان واحدا من مجموعه ضربات
زرعت عدم الثقه واذكت التوتر مع قطاع
صناعه الوقود الاحفوري في امريكا في عهد
الاداره الحاليه وفقا لمقابلات مع
المديرين التنفيذيين وغيرهم من العاملين
في مجال النفط والغاز حسب وكاله بلومبيرج
مخزونات الوقود وصلت الى مستويات منخفضه
لدرجه مقلقه نهايه اكتوبر الماضي الامر
الذي تسبب بحدوث حاله استنفار في البلاد
بلال البوجداني العربيه